this is an x-ray of a broken rib cage
spinning at 45 rotations per minute and
there's a sound coming from those tiny
grooves etched into the x-ray film how
else would you listen to illegal music
in Soviet Russia
[Music]
the many great things about the Soviet
Union but in terms of what you could
listen to watch read etc it was subject
to a censor so there was no freedom in
that sense at all that's Steven Coates
of the Bureau of lost culture based in
London
Stephen studies a myriad and ingenious
ways people skirted the Soviet Union's
draconian government censors the music
was seen as both anti intellectual and
also but it might encourage on welcome
behavior as a result this subversive
music was banned but it didn't stop the
people of Soviet Russia from getting
their hands on we had these machines
where you could go into a booth and
people would make souvenir recordings of
their voice but in the evening when the
shop was closed this guy was using his
recording machine to copy forbidden easy
to make what we call bootlegs and he was
giving him to friends or selling them
they had the machine to copy the records
but what medium were they going to
record on commercial blanks like those
you'd find in the West were in short
supply so ingenious soul had discovered
that it was possible to make a record to
cut the grooves of recorded music onto
the surface an x-ray film became a kind
of underground culture more people
started to make x-ray records or people
started to build their own recording
machines and in the dark alleys of the
Soviet Union
bootleggers swapped the sounds of Elvis
from Charlie Parker on Prince of
fractured pelvis is and sprained
shoulders in the mid-1960s a new easier
to use technology would appear on the
scene the reel-to-reel tape recorder the
x-ray black market died soon thereafter
despite advancements in technology
there's still something that brings
Steven back to the x-ray records there
was something poignant and poetic and
romantic about that collision you like
of physical aspects of of being an x-ray
of the body and the content of music
which we normally associate probably
with a soul or with the heart now that's
what I call soul music
[Music]